[Musique]
les vendanges pendant cinq petites
minutes renouvelables à l'envi nathalie
et sa maman s'offre une forme de rêve
réanimer pour découvrir le métier de
viticulteur à travers les quatre saisons
des vendanges en automne à la taille en
hiver et la véraison au printemps toutes
les étapes sont expliqués par le dessin
accessible à tous je savais pas qu'on
pouvait que qui travaillent et août
enfin que même en hiver et tout ça et
travailler vignerons et que si basse et
c'est bien parce qu'on on voit comment c
est comme c'est pas trés avec les
explications difficile tous les mots
difficiles tous ah bah si c'est mieux
c'est vivant il ya là musée qui est
relaxante
et puis on suit un peu le travail des
vignerons des viticulteurs c'est
instructif c'est je pense que c'est
accessible à tous c'est bien aux adultes
qu'aux enfants
la maison des vins de cheverny et nili à
12 ans avec son mode de dégustation high
tech avec un verre muni d'une puce
le visiteur peut découvrir de nombreux
vins de la hausse et cheverny et cour
cheverny là le collectif de viticulteurs
aidé par la région a investi 40 mille
euros dans cette nouvelle vitrine high
tech qui combine vidéo mapping et
rotoscopie ça m'était traditionnel
vignerons mais ce qui est l'idée
intéressante c'est d'être finalement
contemporain en fait se baser sur les
traditions pour la production de vin
mais aussi dans l'avenir avec des
méthodes innovantes
de qualité toujours que ce soit pour la
production comme pour la présentation
la grande majorité de la hausse et se
vend dans les restaurants et à l'export
mise à mal par le cos vide
les particuliers ne représentent que 20%
des ventes
l'objectif de cette nouvelle
installation que les visiteurs qui
viennent d'achever rni notamment pour le
château parle de l'appellation autour
d'eux